that's exactly what chiwa has done in
this ball game
quickly will fire oh
and it goes in at the half and it'll
count
what a play by john calipari arena
field right now there's clark in the
position you love him in and
so does gear that one is picked by
quickly he's ahead of the floor
and he will lay it up and in quick nice
find it's brown
he can't hit the three rebound knocked
to the outside break opportunity
kentucky
slammed down by quickly five on the shot
clock double team black shear all over
quickly he's going to have to force one
up uh-oh
oh you know it's your day baby
seven assists same action quickly
three another one
time tamar has been switched off on a
smaller player he stayed in front
quickly three is nylon
how about that pass that's 68 points
from bench players that was the most
sincere
there is
[Applause]
this is not the easiest kentucky team to
press because they have maximum ball
handlers and that's how you do it
higgins goes cross court montgomery shot
clock winding down
quickly ball fake quickly push it up and
then
emanuel quickly with the delivery
because that took a bucket away
off the screen quickly
floater got it wow
he can elevate montgomery kicks it over
here's a runner by quickly
they can score quickly too can't they
nice legal break
good pass quickly with the steps